another thing that dr bright is not  allowed to do with the foundation dr  bride should be reminded that victims of  scp-217 are not toys nor are they to be  used as props at a steampunk convention  scp-217 also known as the clockwork  virus is a terrifying anomalous pathogen  that slowly converts the organic  material of its victims into analog  mechanized elements eventually leaving  them looking like inoperative steampunk  nightmares of course dr bright has no  permanent body and thus it really  wouldn't hold that much of a threat for  him therefore he could in theory start  treating the infected individuals like  big strange robotic toys but for the  sake of human decency the o5 council  would really really really really prefer  that he didn't